i'm feeling blessed i highly favored you
know
agreed okay so let's talk about the
album so you worked with p
diddy on that album twice as nice um
twice as tall sorry and
i want to know like what was something
you would say you learned from him
because not many people get to work with
someone like diddy
i basically learned that i was doing the
right thing and i was on the right path
you know because it's like he
he basically saw a lot of himself with
me and stuff you know so
that kind of just showed me okay yeah
about to hit them billions
it's a good it's a good comparison to
make burnout it's a good one
all right so i want to talk it's not a
comparison it's like it's a you know
it's a
it's a goal you know it's yeah yeah yeah
and you're in the right company burnout
obviously
because you're a grammy award winner now
all right so
second question i'm going to ask you
yeah take it in take it in and take it
in
so 2020 was quite a turbulent one and
you were leading
in regards to your voices and the
protest in nigeria
what part for you does music play when
it comes to social commentary because
you've been very vocal
i mean for me i believe music is
whatever the spirit
wants to say and not everyone's spirit
wants to you know talk about
what's going on and not everyone's
spirit is in tune with
the environment and the the the ills and
and and clients of the environment you
know so
everyone's got different corners you
know and everyone's spirit
like has a different thing to say you
know so
it just happens that my mind has
has a lot of a lot you know a lot of the
people's
plight and a lot of the realities of of
my life and my existence
you know to explain